time is Zero Dark Thirty the location of
badabod less than 100 miles away from
Pakistan's capital nestled here a
fortress of Secrets a Haven for the
world's most wanted man you know how the
story ends but you don't know how it
started it begins thousands of miles
away deep in the halls of power of the
most technologically advanced Nation on
Earth America this isn't just a story of
Bravery under the cover of night but one
of years filled with Relentless Pursuit
intelligence gathering and geopolitical
maneuverings Operation Neptune Spear
killed Osama Bin Laden and highlighted
the incredible prowess of the Navy Seals
but it also demonstrated the power of
American Technology to decipher coded
messages and connect millions of
invisible threads of intelligence this
is the story of the app that helped
catch Osama Bin Laden this is the story
of palantir it's a secretive company
palantir customers include the CIA the
FBI the Army the Marines the Air Force
yet there's so much mystery around it
and it frustrates people to know no end
these guys palantir are the Rudy
Giuliani of tech confused full of
contradictions and completely out of
touch and back crazy palantir but
they're led by a one-of-a-kind CEO what
are we like we're underpaid we do it
because we love it and we continue doing
it because we love it
understanding palantir really requires
understanding their CEO Alex carp today
he runs a multi-billion dollar public
company and is referred to as Dr carp by
everyone who reports to him but he took
a long and winding road to success he
was born in 1967 and grew up in
Philadelphia both his parents were
forward-thinking progressives who took
him to labor rights protests on weekends
despite struggling with dyslexia from an
early age Alex graduated from Haverford
College in 1989 and went on to study law
at Stanford while at Stanford he roomed
with a guy named Peter Thiel the very
same Peter Thiel who would go on to
build PayPal and Founders fund during
their time at Stanford the two young men
often sparred intellectually teal had
established himself as an outspoken
libertarian as an undergrad even
founding an on-campus newspaper called
the Stanford review carp on the other
hand leaned more socialist but instead
of driving them apart this actually drew
them together they spent many nights
arguing about politics and philosophy
and became close friends after
graduation the two went separate ways
teal went off to the prestigious Law
Firm Sullivan and Cromwell and Alex went
off to continue his studies in Europe it
was at Frankfurt University in Germany
that Alex carp formally became Dr carp
he studied under Jurgen havermas one of
the world's most famous philosophers
earning a PhD in neoclassical social
theory in the process this wound up
being a turning point for the young Dr
carp but not in the way he thought
because even though he had earned his
stripes under a world-renowned academic
he realized that he didn't want that
life so he pivoted it was the turn of
the Millennium the.com boom was in full
swing and Dr carp had developed a
network of high net worth individuals in
Europe who were looking for new
investment strategies he had a knack for
investing but at this stage his
aspirations were still fairly modest he
mostly just wanted to build a small nest
egg and then settle into a casual life
in Berlin to start building toward that
goal he created an investment company in
London called the Cadman group but his
dream of a modest life was soon
interrupted see while Dr carp was off in
Europe Peter Bill had been building an
empire back in the States
he'd started an internet payments
company merged it with a similar project
Elon Musk was building and then taken
the combined entity public under the
name PayPal in 2002 PayPal was acquired
by eBay for 1.5 billion dollars this
made teal a multi-millionaire and his
Ambitions were just getting started
Thiel had seen the damage wreaked by the
attacks on 9 11 and realized that
America was about to change like in the
wake of 9 11 a few years after that was
um could one do something from a
Libertarian or civil liberties point of
view that would still be you know tough
on terrorism a super intrusive
surveillance all the time it wasn't
really making us safer teal became
recently fixated on using technology to
stop terrorist attacks before they
happened that would require working with
a notoriously secretive U.S intelligence
Community but remember that teal had
been a Libertarian for years he wanted
to stop terrorism but he really didn't
want to sacrifice civil liberties in
order to do it he was facing a modern
version of a centuries-old philosophical
problem the problem was most famously
stated by Benjamin Franklin in a letter
from 1755 Franklin wrote those who would
give up essential Liberty to purchase a
little temporary safety deserve neither
Liberty nor safety on top of the ethical
conundrum teal also knew that achieving
his vision would be a formidable
technical challenge so he decided to
assemble a team of people he'd worked
with before both at Stanford and PayPal
Nathan gettings Joe Lonsdale and Stephen
Cohen had all met teal through either
Stanford PayPal or Teal's hedge fund
clarium Capital teal named the startup
palantir after the seeing stones in
tolkien's Lord of the Rings the guys he
brought together were all great but none
of them were quite right for the job of
CEO and this was a big problem teal was
able to provide initial funding for the
company and the team of Engineers was
able to build a functional prototype but
they were struggling to get potential
investors and customers to take them
seriously this wasn't some viral
consumer tech company palantir wanted to
sell to the biggest customer in the
world the US government it was serious
business and this is where Dr carp came
up as an interesting option for a few
years he'd been helping introduce High
net worth individuals to clarium Capital
many of those individuals were connected
to Global intelligence and defense
institutions teal knew that building a
software business that could work
effectively with the intelligence
Community would require a CEO who could
work with big government people he
needed someone smart who could bridge
the gap between palantir and the
intelligence Community he thought about
it and then he decided to call up his
old friend Dr Alex carp Tia later said
that at the time he wasn't sure that
Alex was the perfect person for the job
but that he possessed the right
qualities even though he'd never been a
CEO he clearly understood the mission
and could build a solid team the team
Alex put together had all the skills to
build a good product but actually
selling it to the US government was a
different challenge entirely and if they
were going to solve it they would need
to be patient because when it came to
counterterrorism progress was measured
in years not days despite being their
Global number one target it took the US
military almost a decade after 9 11 to
catch Bin Laden the process of finding
him was long winding and full of
setbacks and near-misses effective
counter-terrorism requires synthesizing
lots of different sources of
intelligence intercepting Communications
between militants talking to people on
the ground and clever use of informants
and just Gathering the data wasn't
nearly enough you needed to get
different agencies to collaborate with
each other in order to detect the
underlying patterns the U.S national
security establishment made lots of
mistakes the first big one came just a
few months after 9 11. the US government
established a program called total
information awareness the idea was to
correlate detailed information about
people in order to anticipate and
prevent terrorist attacks before they
place the man leading the charge here
was Admiral John Poindexter he was a
highly controversial figure he'd retired
from the Navy in 1987 and was convicted
of multiple felonies stemming from the
Iran Contra affair although the
conviction was later overturned on
appeal he returned to the government
during the George W Bush Administration
to head up the information awareness
office which was run out of DARPA the
pentagon's special research projects
agents on paper the goal was simple to
bring together as much information as
possible about terrorist networks in
order to identify the most pressing
threats Poindexter referred to the
program as a Manhattan project for
counterterrorism but it was short-lived
it was heavily criticized for sounding
like a program that allowed the US
government to spy on all of its citizens
Poindexter resigned in August of 2003
and the information awareness office was
disbanded even though the US government
secretly maintained much of its core
architecture that didn't matter to
Poindexter who was on the outside but he
was still a useful asset for anyone who
wanted to sell security products to the
US government in other words he was a
useful asset to Peter Thiel and Alex
carp what palantir does it sort of is a
way for you know patterns and data to be
visualized through a combination of
computers and human analysts and then in
a way that doesn't simply scour the
planet there's something suspicious then
you look some more and in that sense
it's it's way less intrusive during the
PayPal years TL had struggled to detect
fraudulent transactions on the payment
Network even though PayPal had signed up
millions of users the company was losing
as much as 10 million dollars every
month to credit card fraud the issue was
so dire that visa and MasterCard
threatened to cut ties with PayPal
unless the company got on top of the
problem fortunately PayPal CTO Max
levchin stepped up he built a program to
scan through transactions and flag
suspicious behavior for manual review he
named the program Igor in honor of the
Russian hacker who'd been the biggest
thorn in his side Igor was so good that
not only did it solve PayPal's fraud
problem it actually exposed the identity
of two Russian cyber criminals who were
promptly arrested by the FBI the
experience of searching for a few small
criminal operations in the massive data
set of PayPal transactions would prove
very useful for palantir terrorism is
asymmetric asymmetry presupposes
software because you're finding needles
and Haystacks it's not exactly like data
mining was a critique on some of the
data mining approaches that had been
used at PayPal and we thought that that
approach would be very effective in this
context it was 2004. teal and carp had
assembled a growing team of Hardcore
Engineers focused on shipping at
Breakneck speed the palantir team moved
into an office in Palo Alto which in
keeping with the Lord of the Rings theme
they nicknamed The Shire and they got
down to work after months of arduous
days long programming sessions and too
many energy drinks to count the palantir
team cobbled together a prototype the
palantir Prototype was designed to link
disparate databases and then let anyone
even if they weren't a programmer search
and visualize the information contained
within most importantly everything that
happened with in palantir software would
be logged so it could be audited by
authorities classified data wouldn't be
able to be accessed by just anyone you
needed to have proper clearance and
proper justification for an
investigation all of that was critical
if they were going to get the US
government on their side the team had
already put in a huge amount of work
building the Prototype but they knew the
hardest part of their job was just about
to begin so we have this this meeting
it's only two months away and uh you
know we don't exactly have too much
product at the time it was a little
admittedly light on the back end
elements the initial prototype a little
more focused on the lights and the
fireworks and the the front end the
Prototype demonstrated the value that
palantir could provide to the government
and because it had been built by
Engineers who had experience delivering
products that people actually used
regularly like PayPal it was intuitive
palantir clearly believed their product
could make a difference in the war on
terror but selling to the government is
more than just building a functional
product often even having the best
product isn't enough you have to
convince dozens of different decision
makers and Wade through miles of red
tape in hindsight I think the palantir
team believed that their product would
sell itself but that's not what happened
we did a very bad job making our case it
was very difficult we didn't understand
what they were saying they didn't
understand what we were saying this team
of Engineers who were used to moving
extremely fast came up against the
immovable object that was the US
government and they were left
disappointed this setback was compounded
by the fact that without any customers
Silicon Valley investors weren't exactly
lining up to pour in money Peter Thiel
had invested millions of dollars of his
own money into palantir but other
Venture capitalists weren't interested
in selling to the government when VC
from Sequoia spent the entire pitch
meeting doodling while another lectured
the palantir founders for over an hour
and a half about how their company was
going to fail this is deeply ironic
because Silicon Valley was built on
strong Partnerships with the American
Military early semiconductor companies
were spun out of government-funded
research labs and lots of early tech
companies received funding from the
Department of Defense but by the
mid-2000s it was like like Silicon
Valley and Washington spoke different
languages there's one guy in Silicon
Valley who became particularly
frustrated by this turn of events his
name's Steve blank and he's a professor
at Stanford who has studied how tech
companies have worked with the military
over the past Century get companies like
Andrew or palantir or SpaceX yeah to be
major defense contractors it required a
billionaire that's insane I mean maybe
should people who should be in jail for
that I wanted to know more about why
it's so hard for tech companies to work
with the US government so I flew to
Stanford and asked Professor blank
directly it's not that innovators and
whether they're startups or scale-ups or
Venture firms Etc don't want to work
with a DOD and the dod has no conception
of what Innovation at scale could do for
us and and fundamentally they're simply
not organized to do that their Corp
charges are on they have the wrong
people in place see over the course of
the 90s and early 2000s the U.S defense
industry went through a massive wave of
consolidation until it was left with
just a handful of prime contractors
these primes won the overwhelming
majority of government defense contracts
if the US government wanted a new
software system they wouldn't ask some
small Silicon Valley startup they would
just pick up the phone to Lockheed
Martin Booze Allen or IBM if palantir
wanted to break through to the US
government they'd need something to
change
fortunately Dr carp wasn't just going to
sit around and hope to get lucky one of
the VC funds that had turned palantir
down for investment was willing to make
an introduction to incutel a non-profit
Venture Capital firm run by the CIA in
order to fund Innovation that could help
the intelligence Community the palantir
team met with the head of incutel a man
named Gilman Louie and pitched him on
their idea for an integrated data
platform that's how palative got started
the pilot care was this Peter Thiel and
Alex basically meeting with me and
saying we got these algorithms on
fraudulent transactions we think there
might be some value for the intelligence
community and then immediately we took
that team and put them inside the
building to work on what we call a CT
counter-terrorist problem we're still
just a couple years into palantir's
Journey George W Bush was president the
US military was still in Iraq and
Afghanistan and Bin Laden was still at
large but palantir's luck was finally
starting to improve after struggling to
get his foot in the door for months Dr
carp was able to meet with lots of
government officials and start learning
what it would take for them to buy
palantir software but that didn't mean
the meetings always went well the
cultural divide seemed as big as ever
the agency officials Dr cart met with
were often skeptical of his relaxed
style and they had lots of questions for
him was his team cleared to work with
classified documents had they ever
worked with intelligence agencies before
did they have senior advisors with
government experience was their sales
force built to work with classified
information the answer to all these
questions was no but that didn't
discourage Dr carp in the palantir team
for them no didn't mean never it just
meant not yet everyone they pitched
could tell that even though they lacked
the credentials and experience from
working with the government this team
could deliver on one visit to the
palantir offices a senior intelligence
official saw sleeping bags under the
engineer's desks clearly the pace of
play at palantir was completely unlike
anywhere else Gilman Louie the head of
incutel acted as an anchor for palantir
at the CIA in qtel invest two million
dollars and helped connect palantir to
CIA analysts in Langley Virginia every
two weeks palantir Engineers would fly
from Palo Alto to Langley with an
updated version of the software they
were building the CIA analysts would
test it out and offer feedback then the
engineers would fly back to California
to implement the suggested changes today
this kind of arrangement is standard
practice at palantir they even have a
name for employees who embed themselves
within the customer they are building
software for they call them forward
deployed engineers and it's been a
critical part of their success one of
the kind of points that I think
demarcated an element of success was
when my government sponsor was
introducing me at one of these meetings
and he said everyone I want to introduce
you to Mr two weeks he can he can build
anything you ever want in two weeks so
ask away it's another one of those
that's what you want to hear definitely
increase my Red Bull consumption word
was spreading within the US government
about the intensity that the palantir
team brought to problem solving they
were building and iterating extremely
quickly and most importantly they knew
where they should be focused when
inqutel executive said that the most
impressive thing about the team was how
focused they were on the problem of how
humans would talk with data things were
beginning to go in the right direction
but solving the problem of human
computer interaction in a way that would
scale past a single organization would
take them years the basic idea was how
do you extend the human mind into an
Enterprise to get the full power of the
human mind the problem with that idea is
there's not one data set there's five or
ten or fifty palantir needed to build a
system that allowed humans and computers
to work together effectively well
there's uh there's a tremendous amount
that we can do in in combining computers
with with humans that we either have all
Human Solutions or all Computer
Solutions there's a lot to be done with
these intermediate hybrid Solutions it
turns out that if you get the division
of labor right you can do a lot Dr carp
had always been focused on building a
world-class team and not just in
Engineering in 2006 he tired to serve as
the Chief Operating Officer of the
company he's still with palantir today
although he's switched his title to the
chief technology officer treyam was
convinced that real world problems could
only be solved by combining the
abilities of humans and computers he had
extensively studied the work of a man
named jcr lichlider a Pioneer in the
field of man computer symbiosis and an
important figure in the development of
the internet sham believed that the key
to making good decisions in complex
situations wasn't depending on
predetermined programs but instead for
man and machine to cooperate to test
hypotheses if this sounds slightly
abstract it had real-world applications
to the work palantir was doing computers
don't detect novel patterns and new
behaviors or humans do humans using
technology by asking machines to do
things for them Osama Bin Laden was not
caught by artificial intelligence he was
got by dedicated resourceful brilliant
people in Partnerships with various
Technologies after months of trying Dr
karp had won over the CIA and palantir
software was finally starting have an
impact in the fight against terrorism
but the fight was happening on several
fronts after all terrorism was a threat
in American cities but it also posed a
threat to members of the U.S military
stationed abroad the Army needed to
identify and track potential attackers
just as urgently as the CIA so palantir
saw an opportunity to expand their
product offering but if they thought
selling software to the CIA was tough
they were about to face an even bigger
challenge part of the reason why selling
to the Department of Defense was so
tough was because of the defense primes
so rather than take on multi-billion
dollar leviathons Dr carp and his team
adopted an orthodox strategy instead of
focusing on lobbying the Pentagon like
other major defense contractors they
introduced their product to soldiers
directly the plan worked like this
palantir with contact soldiers and offer
free training on their software they
would also give out funding to support
the work of soldiers who would be
working with data when they deployed
this approach helped to create internal
demand for palantir software inside the
military soldiers already knew how well
the software worked and could start
advocating for it internally but getting
troops to be comfortable with
complicated software wouldn't be easy a
couple of months ago I sat down with the
CEO of anderol Matt Grimm who worked at
palantir around the time they started
deploying software to troops in the
Middle East he remembered just how
difficult it was uh and then pound here
at that time had just deployed to their
first customers they thought that their
product was so intuitive and so easy
that we would just deploy it and it
would just be like that aha moment which
is just not not so then it was like just
a Litany of help desk it was yet another
culture shock after spending ages trying
to learn the language of the government
palantir now had to learn how to deal
with the military and the first thing
they had to learn was that getting
soldiers comfortable with the software
was just as important as actually
building the software over time the plan
worked and soon high-ranking Military
Officers were meeting with the palantir
team to discuss using the software in
Afghanistan now this could have been
completely smooth sailing except for one
thing the U.S military had already
signed up for a 10 billion dollar
project to build a similar system
internally it was created in the late
1990s by U.S military services called
the distributed common ground surface
system known as d-cigs the program was
designed to be a massive data sharing
system and a major weapon for the war on
terror all of the biggest defense
contractors had signed on to build
d-cigs basically d-cigs was too big to
fail but it was still failing it was
clunky and prone to crashing but
military officials had spent years
developing the requirements for the
software and wanted to see their
internal programs see the light of day
palantir wasn't built by the military it
was built by a team of Silicon Valley
Engineers who had no prior experience
working with the government but
remarkably it was still winning the
battle for hearts and Minds if we had a
unit come to us and and say that that it
actually saved lives because they were
able to plot out where all the IEDs were
and they said they actually had a huge
increase in IEDs found and that's a big
deal because IEDs are the number one
killer and wounding mechanism of the bad
guys in Afghanistan
palantir was winning over both ground
troops and the people who led them
General Jim Mattis supported the program
as did Lieutenant General H.R McMaster
but not every higher up liked palantir
and a situation that was already
complicated became even more complicated
when Congress started asking questions
about how much the program was costing
American taxpayers we have more
capability today and our intelligence
than we've ever had a company Commander
today with these six
20 times the capability I had as a
division commander in 2003. our Intel
organizations moved forward greatly
despite intense scrutiny from some
military officials palantir was still
overwhelmingly popular with soldiers
according to a 2012 study commissioned
by the Army 96 of military personnel
deemed palantir software effective you'd
think that this would have been amazing
news for palantir but it wasn't think
about it they had all this support from
soldiers on the ground and they still
weren't getting anywhere the military
basically ignored that report and kept
doing business as usual for two years
everyone was treading water that was at
least until the Army finally decided
that enough was enough they realized
that the desig system would never work
like they wanted it to so the dod began
soliciting bids to develop a replacement
to d-cigs Dr karp and the palantir team
finally had the Breakthrough they'd been
waiting for except it wasn't quite like
that the Army refused to allow palantir
to participate in the new bidding
process because its software was an
off-the-shelf product they only wanted
to hear from defense contractors who
would promise to build an entirely new
system from scratch now to some degree
that made sense everyone wants something
tailor-made to their specific needs the
Army wanted a system that would be
perfect but this would be a disaster if
it went forward 96 of soldiers already
thought that palantir software was good
enough for the Army and the software was
getting better every day when the
palantir team made improvements for one
government agency it would be easy to
make those improvements available to the
Army but the Army didn't have much
experience building and running
successful software programs so they
rejected palantir yet again a government
agency and a Silicon Valley startup just
didn't speak the same language Dr carp
and the team were backed into a corner
they knew that palantir could make a
difference on the battlefield but
government bureaucracy was getting in
the way as the old saying goes desperate
times call for desperate measures so
palantir sued the US government
the federal court only took three months
to rule in palantir's favor the judge
said that the Army had acted in an
arbitrary and capricious Manner and
ordered that palantir be included in the
bidding process this was a big win for
palantir they would finally be a
first-class citizen in the world of
military contractors rubbing shoulders
with the primes but just as they'd
solved their DOD problem a new problem
emerged see at the end of the day the
government just didn't spend all that
much money on software sure the United
States spends trillions of dollars every
year on the military broadly but only a
tiny amount of that goes towards
software D6 was a 10 billion dollar
program but that was spread over decades
and besides people were getting
uncomfortable with even that amount of
spending palantir had Ambitions to grow
to the same size as other Silicon Valley
Tech Giants but getting a small part of
a 10 billion dollar contract simply
wouldn't be enough they needed to expand
and fast despite their early problems
raising money Dr carp and the rest of
the palantir team had actually gotten
pretty good at it over the years they
now had a clear goal take the company
public an evaluation in the tens of
billions of dollars but that goal looked
a long way away things were getting kind
of desperate palantir needed something
big to happen involving their technology
and in the early hours of May 2nd 2011
in that compound in a badabad they got
just what they wanted
it's actually hard to say for sure just
how big of a role palantir software
played in finding Osama Bin Laden the US
Army just doesn't share those kinds of
details especially when it comes to
killing the world's most notorious
terrorist but the Whispers started right
away no one at palantir ever said
anything about it the whole thing much
like palantir itself is shrouded in
secrecy but something that is clear is
that in the Years following Bin Laden's
assassination palantir became the
government's go-to company when they
needed to make sense of big data sets
for military and law enforcement
purposes part of that is the rise of big
data in general around 2012 there was a
major turning point big corporations
were starting to store increasingly
large amounts of data this realization
that companies and governments were
sitting on valuable troves of data
opened up big opportunities for palantir
Dr karp and his team started expanding
on palantir's offerings to solve a
variety of problems for non-governmental
organizations they partnered with JP
Morgan to build Financial software they
worked with Airlines to help optimize
flight routes and they landed a big deal
with Airbus to improve nearly every
aspect of how they built airplanes the
Airbus deal is a particularly good
example of how palantir helps large
organizations and unlike the bin Laden
case we can actually talk about this one
in 2016 Airbus was ramping up production
of its new a350 jet but they quickly ran
into a problem going from manufacturing
one single plane to building dozens
would increase the complexity of all
their processes exponentially missing
parts production mistakes communication
glitches all these problems would slow
down the assembly process and cause
millions of dollars of cost overruns and
Airlines don't like waiting for delivery
of the planes they've ordered they often
demand compensation for any delays to
solve all these issues five Ford
deployed palantir Engineers flew to the
Airbus Factory in Toulouse France and
set up shop while on site they merged 25
different data silos related to the
production of the a350 this produced
results immediately reducing the number
of delays to fixed production mistakes
and realizing hundreds of millions of
dollars in savings palantir was
eventually rolled out to thousands of
Airbus employees and today information
from nearly every Airbus plane flows
through palantir for analysis to improve
reliability and safety building out this
air travel business seemed like a good
idea at the time and it was a good idea
at the time but then at the start of
2020 the whole world got an important
lesson in why air travel is a volatile
business governments responded to the
outbreak of covid by introducing
restrictive lockdowns planes everywhere
were grounded and if you can't fly why
do you need planes but you should never
let a crisis go to waste as the pandemic
started to spread globally Dr carp and
his team started to see an opportunity
to help by now they had 15 years of
experience working with governments and
handling sensitive data so there had to
be a way for palantir to make a positive
impact and then to offer our product for
free to combat covet rebuilding Supply
chains figuring out who and under what
conditions people were becoming infected
they wound up working closely with the
U.S Department of Health and Human
Services to urge around 2 billion data
elements related to the outbreak to help
government officials get a clearer
picture of how the virus was spreading
they even partnered with the United
Nations world food program to help get
food and supplies distributed during the
pandemic this kind of work came as a
surprise to palantir's many critics who
thought that the company could only work
with the military and despite the
difficulty of the pandemic there was
another Silver Lining prior to the
outbreak of covid Dr carp was extremely
focused on getting Engineers embedded
with the organizations they were helping
it's better to have Engineers figuring
out what the core issues are and then
iterate against them we are not planning
to hire sales people we still haven't
hired any or we don't really hire
non-technical people very often and we
don't have a marketing department and
we're not planning to get any of them
the problem was that all these forward
deployed Engineers were extremely
expensive palantir was spending millions
of dollars flying these people around
the world and putting them up in hotels
while they helped their customers
implement the software the covid
revealed that maybe they could be just
as a effective while working remotely
without the option to travel palantir
just naturally cut costs significantly
and interestingly Revenue kept climbing
17 years after it was founded palantir
ipo'd in September of 2020 at an initial
evaluation of 15.2 billion dollars today
the company is in a much healthier
position and poised to continue growing
part of this positive outlook is that
it's also at the heart of the next big
technological Trend AI large language
models have taken the World by storm and
every company that can claim even a
tangential relation to the technology
has benefited but palantir has actually
been working on artificial intelligence
for years yeah unlike most people we've
been involved in what people call AI for
the last five six seven years in the
classified environment Building Systems
that will allow you to identify
adversarial positions you can tell that
he's a little annoyed there because
everyone is jumping on the AI bandwagon
so it's easy to put palantir in the same
bucket as all the other companies that
are just riding the hype wave right now
but they're happy for their work to do
the talk
palantir has faced lots of criticism
over the years some of it has come from
other tech companies who turn their nose
up at working with the military Lots has
come from civil Libertarians who believe
that palantir helped build technology
that's been used to spy on American
citizens and some of it has come from
people who believe that palantir is more
of a consulting company than a software
company basically their criticism is
that palantir builds too much custom
software for each customer which hurts
the versatility of the core palantir
product but as AI becomes more useful
for processing information and gleaning
insights from large data sets their
products should naturally become more
generalizable the story is far from over
though palantir is now a 20 year old
company but Dr Carr the former
philosopher who went rogue is still the
CEO does he wrestle with the ethics of
the company he runs maybe he does but he
also believes that everything we take
for granted in our democracy is
underpinned by National Security America
continues to need the support of tech
companies and Dr carp understands the
importance of a stable World Order big
Tech has had a tumultuous history with
the Department of Defense palantir had
to sue the government to get a fair shot
and a contract Google on the other hand
dropped out of a major military AI
program to understand why you just have
to watch this video next thanks a lot